お前等逆るトップしてるとよくルートなんですよ
まあまあまあまあ地中人もいるでしょうね
まあいわゆる乳酸菌量というずございますまあ今冬雨の
ばこの寒い冬の時期ねやっぱ風に彼がやすくなる理由を風にそれをねしているためにね
こういうで乳酸菌やで平らに取り込んで可能
の耐性を高めるというのも一つの対策のお茶として1からんですけどまぁバカヤロなら
本何言うなよくれと1本ぐらいどんどん勝手なウイルスに普通にかかるんですよ
よね今回はでっヤクルト一見10本ノア
no トランスなぁ分かりますここ100本ピッってほしいと思う君たちがいると思う
んだよねきゃっポンッ
ねっまあ普通に考えて普通に考えて腹壊します
体にも良くないんで10本ぐらいがちょうどいい感じかなと思ってね
黒10本の早飲みに挑戦しようと思います僕多分飲むの早いんですよだいぶ取れこれ
挑戦者求むからさちょっとルールは明確に取得はルールとしてはとりあえずね2は空け
ておいていいです
でも開けておきましょう
いややいけるでしょ
総裁にちょっと風邪だからさたまには乳酸菌を取り入れようと思ってでちょうどいいん
ですよ
でまぁルールとしてはですねスタートしてから持ってスタートです
で10分面倒見終わっておいた瞬間終了ですその間の対応競います
ちょっとどれぐらいかの123
4号ヨガれた僕はいけると思いますよちょっ
ブーバーけど1本大変だから言いますじゃあ
多い佐藤
read me
久保の
me
2分
うわぁ
me
wh
ん
うわぁうわぁああふんっあ一応ちゃんと全部飲みました
みましたよねみたよねづぐしてないからねチートもしれないから正統派
ファイターはじめんですでキンネルタイムですね ua
25秒80です
i 俺の
ん
俺の25秒80個して皆
あっざーじゃあ
あんまり
いうもんじゃないね